and now 10 rip-roaring 20 slang terms
due for a comeback gams legs
specifically the ladies get a load of
them gams on Louise her legs elect a
stock pocket they go up up up and up
forever spiffed located drunk
we got implicated at the gin joint and
wisely invested all of our money in the
stock market boo strong performance will
surely continue to the thirties forties
and fifties the cat's meow a person or
thing that is extremely excellent
America's economic performances to cats
meow I tell you giggle water any drink
with alcohol oh god I just lost
everything I'm ruined
I need me a giggle water and quick do
dropper a young unemployed man who
sleeps all day
what malarkey now everyone will think
I'm a no-good lollygaggin do dropper
applesauce and expletive there are no
jobs anywhere and the trouble boys what
miss lapsed Oh applesauce clams money
how many clams can I get but sell in my
blood I've got a whole trench coat
covered in and stuff right here big
sleep death fake my old Big Sleep it
sounds crazy but I have nothing left to
lose
no one's onions to be well-informed on a
subject matter this FDR fella sure seems
to know ones onions I'm sure he'll turn
the economy around lickety-split ducky
alright this New Deal sure is ducky and
now that everyone recognizes the wisdom
of long-term economic planning the
economy will be ducky forever